I've spent more than 100 hours playing
Hogwarts Legacy across multiple
playthroughs and today I want to share
my top 10 tips for new players so one of
the first important decisions you need
to make is your difficulty and Hogwarts
Legacy has four settings for you to pick
from if you're a seasoned gamer I highly
recommend going with the hard option
I've played a lot of games over the
years and usually start on normal that's
what I did in Hogwarts Legacy but as
soon as I tried the hard mode I found I
enjoyed it much more than before and
actually wish I had started with that
all along now on the flip side of that
if you're an inexperienced gamer maybe
someone who bought a system just to play
Hogwarts like I see you should probably
start on the story mode which is the
easiest difficulty setting and honestly
I really only recommend that mode for
the most inexperienced Gamers so if
you're someone who has any experience
with games even if it's been a while
since you played I really think you'll
be fine on the easy difficulty possibly
even on normal the next thing you'll
want to tweak are your camera and HUD
options I mentioned before that I play a
lot of games and when I first started
playing Hogwarts something felt very odd
about the camera settings and the way
things were moving the two settings that
made a huge difference for me was
turning the camera acceleration
completely off that's right it's
actually enabled by default so you have
to go in and turn this off and then from
there I just had to bump up the
sensitivity to my liking also make sure
you carefully consider the camera
relative targeting option switching this
to off will actually let you target
enemies off screen and I've actually
heard of a lot of people who end up
liking this much better personally I was
completely fine with it on because I
usually try to lock onto enemies most of
the time using R3 anyway and you can use
R3 to lock on regardless of which one of
these that you have but basically if you
have a camera relative on then to be
able to fire spells at a person they
have to be in your camera view for you
to do so whereas if that's off you can
fire enemies off screen now when it
comes to the HUD overall I personally
prefer a very minimal HUD I actually
played most of my first playthrough with
the minimap completely off now you
definitely sacrifice a lot of on-screen
information by having the minimap off
but I think it helps with the overall
immersion of really you feel like you're
in the world when you do have it off
just remember whether you have it on or
off you can always press up on the d-pad
which will display a golden trail that
allows you to follow your destination so
long as you have the place marked on the
map and this is really useful for
navigating the castle with or without
the minimap now the good news about all
of this is that you can change these
settings even those difficulty options
as many times as you want to get things
just right number three exploration do
not do it early now I know for many of
you the first thing you'll want to do is
set out exploring this gorgeous world
that Avalanche has created and trust me
it is gorgeous but honestly guys I would
encourage you not to do that early in
the game I know it'll be hard to resist
it's honestly what I did myself and it
resulted in a bit of frustration because
I didn't have a broom yet and there were
a lot of things in the world that I
hadn't been taught by the game yet and I
think they did a really good job if you
actually just stick to the first handful
of main missions the game is going to
take you to many of the locations that
you want to visit anyway all you have to
do is just stick to those main quests
then after unlocking a few more spells
and understanding the overall mechanics
a bit more that's when I would encourage
you to start exploring and speaking of
the broom if you want to get it as fast
as possible you need to stick to those
main missions and knock them out as
quickly as you can but I have to stress
here this is quite a few hours into the
game it's still early in the grand
scheme of things but much later than I
expected there are also certain missions
and items that you can only access based
on the time of day and while the game
doesn't really go out of its way to show
you this feature you can manually choose
to alter the time of day by waiting and
skipping ahead all you have to do is
pull up the map and you'll see it right
here in the bottom right corner our next
tip here is all about gear and cosmetics
Hogwarts Legacy has a transmog system
but if you aren't a gamer that's
familiar with this it can be a bit
confusing at first to start it's very
important to understand there's a
difference between the appearance of
your gear and the actual item you'll
start the game with only 20 total gear
slots and that's all of your items
combined so while at first it may appear
that it's 20 for each item that 20 is
actually for every thing and trust me it
fills up fast but more on that in a
second okay so when it comes to the gear
and appearances you'll always want to
make sure that you are equipping your
highest level gear even if you don't
like its appearance because you can
change it all you have to do is go into
the gear menu and press X if you're on
Playstation a if you're on Xbox and
you'll open up a sub menu for that
specific piece of gear which you can
compare to your other items in the same
slot and you'll see if you have anything
better pay attention to the traits as
well you'll unlock something later in
the game that will let you apply
completely new traits to gear so that
one is not as important early on but
some of the gear that you pick up will
actually already have a trait applied
once you have your best gear equipped
then you can back out to the main gear
menu and this time when you hover over a
piece of gear note the appearance button
prompt here so it will be square for
PlayStation and x for Xbox and here is
where all your appearances for gear are
stored so you aren't Limited in the
total number like you are with the
actual gear piece also things like the
dark arts cosmetic the house fanatic and
the twitch cosmetic drops they will all
appear here because they are not
considered a piece of gear rather they
are a cosmetic instead so this is a
really player friendly system because it
means you can have whatever stats you
want in addition to the look you want
what's even better is that you'll keep
all of those appearances even after you
sell the piece of gear whenever you
obtain a new piece of gear that's going
to instantly unlock that as an
appearance as well so don't be
disappointed if you're traveling through
the world finding lower level gear
because you can still use it as a
cosmetic even if the gear itself is
lower level and you can simply sell the
gear piece and this leads right into our
next tip which is all about managing
your gear so one of my early
frustrations with Hogwarts Legacy was
that I constantly found new gear but I
was also frequently running out of space
in my inventory remember you start with
only 20 slots total so there are three
ways to free up space the first is to
Simply destroy the piece of gear this is
the easiest one to do because you can do
it anytime anywhere you go into your
menu hover over the item and hold L3 but
even though this is the easiest to do
you should only do this as a last resort
the second option is that you can sell
these extra items to any vendor in the
game doesn't matter where they're
located or what they normally sell just
remember because the difference between
gear and appearance is you can destroy
or sell any piece of gear and still keep
the appearance for it the best solution
though for the gear storage problem is
to start completing the Merlin trials
puzzles as soon as you unlock them in
game these puzzles are actually the key
to unlocking more overall gear slots so
if you want to get that number up from
20 Merlin puzzles that's how you do it
oh and to even be able to complete these
Merlin trials you'll need to make sure
that you stock up on mallow sweet leaves
which you can buy or grow your own later
in the rumors requirement as far as the
actual puzzles go I think they're pretty
well balanced in terms of the overall
challenge but if you come across any
that feel really difficult it's possible
you just don't have the spell you need
to complete it some of the trials do
require very specific spells that you
may not have access to yet and the game
won't tell you this so you could be
struggling with hours on one of these no
I'm not speaking from experience you're
trying to find the solution but in
reality you just need a new spell so I
would recommend learning each of the
spells in game as soon as you have the
opportunity because it's just going to
open up the game so much more in terms
of everything you can do and unlock now
I remember how I said you unlock more
gear slots by completing Merlin trials
unfortunately this is not something that
automatically happens and that is where
our next tip comes in this is all
related to your challenges page even
though I had been doing many of the
Merlin puzzles early on I noticed I
wasn't unlocking anything or adding any
gear slots so it's very important you
have to frequently check on your
challenges page in the field guide and
this is where you're going to unlock
additional perks and items for
completing challenges throughout the
world the game will prompt you to be
fair when you have a new one but it's
very easy to kind of ignore that as
you're out exploring and doing something
else in the world especially if you're
in the middle of a big battle but just
remember even when you complete these
challenges you'll need to go into the
menu and then unlock the reward for the
challenge you just completed speaking of
the Field Guide when it comes to that
challenges tab do not ignore this in
fact the only way that you can level up
in Hogwarts Legacy is by completing
Field Guide challenges and these are not
limited to is combat so all of the
bravellio pages that you collect the
Merlin trials several other things all
of these are also challenges and
completing them rewards you with
experience so long as there's actually a
challenge that you're working toward
when it comes to the combat challenges
Avalanche has created an engaging spell
system that I think is fun one that I
still have not tired of even after so
many hours with the game now one of the
things that will really help you out in
combat is knowing enemy strengths and
weaknesses most enemies in the game are
going to have a specific spell that
they're weak to and this is where you'll
want to make sure that you don't ignore
the field guidebook because this book is
just a treasure Trove of information
that can be really helpful in battle so
navigate to the collections page and
you'll find a category for enemies and
here you'll be able to find an entry for
every single enemy that you've met so
far in the game and if you read the
entry you'll see a tip or two about how
best to deal with them in badly our next
tip is all about health regeneration
that's right your health will regenerate
in Hogwarts Legacy potions do play a big
role and the one that you'll be using
most often is the wig and weld healing
potion but don't waste is because there
are certain moments where your health
actually regenerates let me explain so
let's let you take a few hits during a
fight and you lose some health Your
Instinct may be to use wig and weld
right away but if you think there's a
chance you could finish that fight
without dying just go ahead and do that
save the Wigan weld don't spam it as
soon as the fight is over but the reason
you don't want to spam it here is
because your health will actually
regenerate once you've cleared the area
of enemies and the threats are no longer
in your immediate vicinity what's crazy
is the game never tells you this or if
it did I completely missed it I may have
wasted just a few potions at the end of
Fight simply because I wanted to make
sure my health was topped off after the
battle before I got into a new fight you
know it's normal right top off your
health but it's actually completely
unnecessary here you can even use this
to your advantage in the battle arenas
because your health it will region in
between those waves of enemies so just
remember if you end a fight and your
health is not at Max simply wait a few
seconds and you'll see it refill all the
way without ever needing to use any of
your potions as great as this is there
will definitely still be times when you
need the wig and weld healing potion and
fortunately they're pretty to come by
you can carry up to 25 of these and
while you can buy them from Pippin's
potions and even find them out in the
world it's going to be much more
efficient to brew your own but you can
only do that once you've unlocked the
room of requirements this will happen
later in the game but when you do get to
that point they're quick to brew they
only require two ingredients [__] Clump
juice and ditney leaves the former which
is quite plentiful throughout the open
world but again you can also purchase at
Pippins in hogsmeade the leaves can be
bought from various shops as well but
you'll want to make sure that you buy
the seeds as soon as you can and then
start growing your own in the room of
requirement all right our next tip here
is easy arithmacy doors as you explore
the Hogwarts Castle you won't have to go
far until you come across one of these
arithmsy doors at first they can be
confusing but there's actually a really
simple way to do this without needing
any sort of guide or cheat sheet so each
magical creature depicted represents a
number and they're in order all around
the door you just have to remember it
starts from zero and not from one the
creature depicted at the very beginning
as a demi guys creatures in the
Wizarding World that can turn invisible
so just remember demigay's invisible
zero and start from there as far as the
actual numbers it's a simple equation
where you need the numbers and symbols
to add up to the one in the middle and
if you're having trouble knowing which
panel to activate all you need to do is
look at the number of question marks in
the middle before you activate the
puzzle you can also look at the
direction of the triangle and whether
it's pointing up or down and then look
at the panel with the triangle pointing
in the same direction set each panel to
the appropriate creature based on the
numbers and you'll knock these out in no
time alright spells I saved the most
important one for last and I have to be
careful here not to show or spoil too
much but let's just say that you'll
reach a point in game where you can
start to buy upgrades for your spells
and you're actually Limited in how many
of these you can buy there's no respect
option currently in the game so you'll
want to be very careful that you're
choosing the upgrades you want for the
most part I would say do what you want
here but the upgrades that are an
absolute must relate to giving yourself
even more spell diamonds to use that's
right being able to switch between
different sets of spells is actually
optional and if you ignore this this
upgrade you will never open up more of
them when you first start the game and
begin learning spells you'll find that
four slots really starts to feel small
rather quick trust me the additional
spell diamonds they're an absolute must
and one extra bonus tip here protego the
shield charm do not sleep on this spell
I've heard from so many people who said
they ended up just dodging and rolling
away from incoming spells and sure
you're gonna have to do this at times
there are even spells that you cannot
use protego against but if you can
master protego and even spend a few
upgrade points on it you'll open up
yourself to even more powerful magic
protego is considered an essential spell
so you won't need to slot it on your
spell diamond instead you'll unlock it
very early on it's always mapped to
Triangle one PlayStation y on Xbox and
while you can simply hold the button for
a few seconds that will keep the shield
up practice the timing here anytime you
see one of those little golden flashes
around your character's head that's when
you need to get ready to tap triangle if
you time it just right though and then
you hold the button down you'll fire off
a Stupify spell and hitting an opponent
with Stupify means they'll take a
additional damage from any of your other
spells for a short period of time
Stupify is really powerful because like
the ancient magic attacks and the
unforgivable spells it will actually
break through any enemy Shield
regardless of the color the exception to
that is The Game's hardest difficulty so
if you're playing that Stupify will not
break through those Shields I actually
think it's one of the most powerful
spells in the game but if you're curious
about other spells and what I think is
the most powerful check out the video on
the right side of your screen now for a
full ranking of every spell in Hogwarts
Legacy as always guys thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon